what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to kick start our reactions
for secret invasion of course joined by John John
how are you great sir secretive koi invading I
read secret invasion in preparation for this the
whole time I was reading I was going this is gonna
be nothing like this show there's a big waste of
time I might as well just re-watch Captain Marvel
and yet Good comic Good comic though it was a
fun time but guys you know what to do leave a
like invade that like button also subscribe and
click the notification Bell to get notified when
our next reaction for secret invasion is up here
in the channel and by the way did a interview with
the director of secret Invasion I think he did an
excellent fantastic job I think people praise it
they said it was the best interview Marvel has
ever received ever feels good feels good don't
make it a secret share it but guys before we go
into this we got a special word from our sponsor
fellow ring bearers this video is brought to
you by none other than Electronic Arts the true
Gandalf of gaming they've crafted a new realm in
Lord of the Rings Heroes of Middle Earth the game
that's going to make you say my precious this
isn't just any game it's your very own journey
into Middle Earth free for all Avengers Hobbits
simply use the link in the description box or pull
a Frodo and scan that QR code on screen join the
ranks of this tactical turn-based squad builder
amassing your fellowship with Heroes like Frodo
and Sam Forge alliances that even the Council
of elrond would approve of and dive head first
into epic quests just like Bilbo you'll stumble
upon a mysterious ring of power the timeline's
fracture and it's your job to fix the broken
Fellowship of time you might even find history
taking a different turn perhaps Boromir won't
try to take the ring this time around here guess
who's stepping up to the plate elrond our very own
half Elven Lord he's coming to the battle on
June 26th the first of the mighty legendaries
with wisdom deeper than the minds of Moria and
power is greater than Gandalf's fireworks he'll
Dazzle you his legendary Adventure event began
June 26th requires you to gather a fellowship of
five Elven characters if you miss out don't worry
there's always more than one way to follow the
fellowship into Middle Earth so are you ready
to join the Battle of our time creating dream
teams facing formidable foes exploring legendary
locations and forging new Destinies with your own
ring of power let's beat on the other side and
may the lights of Arundel guide your path after
all it's dangerous to go alone take this that's
a reference thank you again for sponsoring this
video oh yeah real quick full-length Reaction
watch along We sync up with your own copy of
secretive agent available for a super sexy
rejects over our patreon page but because
this is the first episode first one is public
it is free for everyone so there's a link in the
description box and pin comment you could uh sync
up with us over there if you'd like let's do this
sounds like an alien guys atmospheric
ethereal Moscow hmm the fictional
city of Moscow presently sounds
like Russian music I'll be right
there don't move imagine a world where
information can be trusted this world
Society starts to fray all we can turn to are
the people we care about one of those people
weren't who we thought they were sounds like Heath
Ledger yeah there's been mendelsohn Heathen agent
Prescott five Global terrorists strikes within
the past year Argentina tax Colombia Colombia
attacks the Philippines you think the same
people are behind all of this not people
Scrolls Oh by name I love the presence of this
guy he's a lot it's 30 years ago when the Scrolls
found Earth Carol Danvers and Nick Fury promised
to find them a new planet now they don't want just
any Planet they want ours they need Doctor Who
Scrolls could be anybody anywhere at any time
great Exposition and there is only a tiny
handful known to live on earth you'll know
God my damn what you're talking about Ross the
Larry goes across like a conspiracy theorist the
only scroll contact has been through Nick Fury
there are allies then where is Fury he's unsaver
and if I'm gonna bring him down I need to give him
something more than just theories I need evidence
exciting Love The Dread is
he a scroll I'm wondering
is Ross a squirrel this is the
one that sets the world on fire
it feels like a mission impossible movie yeah
look I'm here to help so let me take this and I'll
give the information to Fury oh he is bad Oh no
you're letting the paranoia get the best of you
I don't know it's already messing
with my mind where's that green
whoa
whoa like his teeny weeny beanie guess neither
were Scrolls but it's already got us paranoid yeah
wow he just casually
I'm like a metro station six blocks Northeast
Zemo it's just him
whoa
cool Sean's so fast so different Martin Freeman's
stunt doubles yep I wanted his floor and run
that's so comic book I love that
look at the purple shading I love it
oh ouch ah
show me your hands rookie Talos it's me
what the hell are you doing here chasing him
well done show here's one of you nah
he's he's one of them real Everett
Ross better be safe immediately like who I'm
so happy this is so good opening credits wow
that's a beautiful artwork I hope it's real
artwork and not just someone's AI Sim fair
that was really cool I really enjoyed that that's
great that might be one of their best ones this is
a really well conceived opening credits setting
the kind of theme and style for the show yeah
beautiful
it was a really well done shot
welcome back to Earth Welcome
To Earth a hug Nick Fury hugged
is that from home that's a scroll Sky plan I am
so sorry me too wow much softer side of Nick after
the blip you were different and they disappeared
Cal Danvers disappeared your daughter disappeared
to where you're young angry though people still
don't have a home she went to Amsterdam ravik is
now the newest member of the scroll Council he
preys on the collective Rage of young displaced
Scrolls where is his ass I like that smart
scrolls are immune to radioactivity and Russia
has the most abandoned nuclear plants on Earth
really smart Prescott had been monitoring a new
radical group called the AAR Americans against
Russia which he believed to be the next scroll
front for a terrorist attack not creative name at
all Americans against Russia and he's going to use
this bomb to do it does he have the materials
for that a weapons cache in Kazakhstan raided
the same day that priscott was killed very nice
if he succeeds your species of cease to exist no
going for a walk you're going for a walk in
Moscow at night yeah oh you're gonna stand out
counting on it I love that we have a situation Mr
President concerning agent Fury who just received
word that he's left saber there he is he's
left yeah Derma moroney that's it president
Fury is building out the most complex
Aerospace defense system in the history
of mankind there's a guy back
there that looked like Trump
yes
wanted to get caught just like
issue number one in the comic
ah damn and I was hoping for a Command
Performance of Old Man River you have
some sort of clock fetish that you've been keeping
from me all these years yes I might have welcomed
you home but I still haven't forgiven you for
destroying my very expensive flat you mean City
what are you doing in Moscow trying to kill
this girl rebellion in his crib you know the
rebel either personally don't you I'm is that why
you came down from your space station you feel
responsible don't answer that what what no about
a heist at a black market storage facility in
Kazakhstan doesn't ring a bell liar you know damn
well what was in that storage for the fact that
you don't know tells me all I need to know about
this new rather old Nick Fury I think thanos's
snap changed you taught you that no matter how
hard you fight for what's right there's always
someone stronger to undermine you ah I mean this
as a friend Fury but go back to your space station
you're in no shape for this fight that lies before
us I'll have one of my thugs to drop you back at
Safe House the show's moving I know I love how his
performance as the wear and tear of someone who's
truly traumatized by the blip and something that
we've been kind of crazy and it's all in Snapchat
this feels more grounded than
the rest of the five years
thank you Sarah Connor take your natural
form yeah don't be ashamed of Who You Are
cool welcome to New skrillos what's it called
scrappingopolis what's your name Peter
when's the last time you ate I don't know
it's called me it's a four course meal
in the glove box these are struggles
we grow only scroll produce here drink scroll
wine West Royal skins whatever dangers you risk
getting here no they're worth it so you can just
put this word scroll in front of anything yeah
this is her scroll mobile yeah so our scroll
headquarters look at them endearing us to
our leadership ways caring for the people I don't
trust her I'm not ready to hate her for hating us
the cinematography of the
show is grounded but excellent
so I score really emotional yeah graphic
provides Refuge but if you do choose to be
a warrior there is one advantage you get to leave
everyone else stays in the compounds the longer
we attach to our shells the less likely we can
be identified by humans and Scrolls alike good
fact good facts travel the world travel the
world meet interesting people and kill them
home bring in the show oh the shell take his face
neat so can you like take their memories with that
thing or something as like a constant
link yeah I'll take his mind sweet
thank you
but the immediate threat Remains the bombs
five specialists in Moscow are capable of
building such an explosive Vasily population
former Chechen Rebel owns a high-end Gallery
in the city center and in a rave now what
do you mean wait until a scroll level picks
up the devices in order to follow them to their
Hideout then yes I totally agree does she see an
ugly ass squirrel like you then she
goes into hunting mode I'm considered
good looking amongst my kindly well I
know a bunch of good looking squirrels
you talking about attacking MI6 operatives
we're on a race with Sonja Falls work she
will annihilate any and everyone who's ever
even heard the name ravik you want to save
innocent Scrolls you're going to have to hurt some
people don't be a pacifist Mercy is your weakness
time for you to prove them wrong let's try cards
check first no mercy they've done such a good job
making the scroll like duplicitousness work
he said take a drink said duplicitousness
I'll go tell everyone we go tomorrow and we
don't stop until Earth Is Ours you come with
me it's time to serve your country you take the
cash to this address you deal with population and
no one else he'll give you two bags you get them
to the Moscow safe house on the store and intact
maybe a million Clark's all right
so far so good she's a really cool
presence like I'm very intrigued by
her the whole time give oppression duh
oh [__]
that was easy not even 40 in human years
you haven't even gone on my mid-life crisis
shopping spree yet oh there's time
what you get for yours The Avengers
what a great way to reference something
that isn't out of tone that was perfect
I'm late for an appointment oh who are
you meeting with my wife this is nice
there belong to Louis XV yeah it has an ex-wife
so we're gonna go ahead and call that a lie
who are you going to meet who does number two
don't be more comfortable in the gallery space
where there is more natural light oh you got any
more than comfortable ass Louis 14 chairs in there
how about dirty bomb I do not know this term
lie number two you're going to shoot
me maybe well probably not right now
there we go yes
Thanos oh
oh I got this is you
whoa
come on yes don't kill him tell me
where the bombs are three on people wow
it's gonna go well
girl fight yeah
how'd you hurt Maria Hill where'd you go
she oh killer Talos no questions asked
change your terms last warning it's what
you always say but there's always another
are you angry this is not what
your mother would have wanted her
last words fine Gaia huh why don't
you ask people that you work for
um I can't you know that I'll protect
you you can't protect anyone gaiah
you're letting Gwen get away
attempted are you to keep saying Duality with all
these complex layers that keeps a lot of
Duality Greg it's almost a show about it
purple and green being opposite sides
of the spectrum of color correct
it is
I love how they were having that in
the mirror yes making friends with
the locals how do you think we kept the Cold
War from going hot lots of like groups like me
can't believe a Marvel show just had that
joke you gonna move I haven't decided see
that's what I'm worried about the fury I knew
was always three steps ahead you've changed man
that's right I think Nick Fury had a child
with a scroll kids definitely the attack
is planned for tomorrow Unity day oh there
are three bombs and graphic knows you'll be
there fracking pods most of their identities
are kept secret even from us there are three
careers including me audit points near vocity
Square I just know if I could trust her I love
how brutal all the dialogue is you just like
shut her down with like that was wonderful
yeah they're gonna mix up the plan good
disguise Nick glasses more glasses wow
Maria Hill no class step it up Maria come on
tell us if I was you I would uh shape-shift
into someone else no he's got glasses on I
like how they've upgraded from the Marvel hat
guys painted ours with
infrared spray infrared got it
got one carrier going Northeast the
other one's South they're all decoys
Follow That Girl cool
they didn't shape-shift with items in
their hands too I think so I just don't
think they can use them as the like
a purpose like they can't make a gun
oh Showdown
thanks it's empty or decoys
Fury's gonna be the only one
that's got an actual mark oh
wow oh dude
just shoot into the crowd Fury yes
oh you lost your specs no no no no no no no
no oh oh my God do not kill Maria kill
Maria on the pilot of the new show
wait a minute that's more bombs
so they can turn them into guns
no oh you gotta be kidding me whoa oh no not cool
no yeah yeah it sucks what I'm not
happy oh God what a cold shot too
I was literally like five minutes thinking ago
thinking that oh this is really cool that we get
to see like Kobe smolders really get a chance to
shine as Maria Hill in a more serious role she's
so good she's so good they really just kill
one of the best actresses I like that choice
yeah Sam I'm holding out hope that it's some
kind of mislead or some kind of some sort of
Espionage like I get it raises the stakes and
shows I understand the choice but the narrative
choice but not the character Choice part of me
it's like but come on we finally got a show where
we really get a chance to hang out with Maria
Hill I've kind of I just love Kobe smolder's
take on her that would have been really special
yeah a little back and forth on that choice
oh well no fridging is good
you guys always the move
her dead body will be in the thumbnail yep I think
that'll go over well for everyone I think that'll
be the way to get happy so we get clicks it's all
about the clicks or with the dead body with a big
arrow pointing to the wound how was I supposed
to snowy to watch the show you even though that
there's tomorrow or whatever wow bold choice that
pilot was absolutely incredible I don't think
there's gonna be a post credit scene which is
Maria he'll wake it up Nick Maria Hill will return
well [__] you Marvel whoa that was saving so
it's interesting as our first Marvel reaction
the three of us have done together where we were
a lot more serious than usual I'm so invested in
such a serious show and they really delivered
on the seriousness that felt very it's very
fascinating to me to take one of the biggest
event comic book runs with a bunch of Marvel
characters it is just craziness and then they
go how are we gonna make the most grounded show
yeah yeah I've heard Disney pleasure out of
this massive event a true adaptation of sorts
um Johnny what did you think my friend lay it on
the line I enjoyed it I thought it was a solid
start and and I mean yeah I like it makes a lot
of sense a story like this to go for these Cold
War you know secret agent Espionage spycraft
sort of story and uh at least thus far I'm very
intrigued I mean you know they're just setting
the stage so there's plenty more twists and turns
to come but I like just re-acquainting with the
fury and Maria Hill R.I.P and Talos and all that
stuff and uh yeah just loving the I don't know
the feeling the vibe the aesthetic the setting
you know being sort of immersed in this Russian
environment I think is a nice change of pace
from from everything and yeah it seems like at
least at the outset they're willing to have along
with you and your Intrigue some interesting
little you know semi-relevant conversations
and whatnot so uh thus far I'm intrigued it's
really interesting how's this kind of King to
conquer koi take it away uh I think my favorite
thing is actually the the pace and tone is it
really trust the audience to let us have so much
dense dialogue that's Exposition heavy but it's
delivered so incredibly well that not only did
it do the thing that I thought wouldn't happen
till two or three episodes in where it is able
to explain what the scrolls are so upset about
that they're willing to change where we left them
so many people were like wait the Scrolls were
good guys at the end of Captain Marvel I didn't
think within the First Act of the first episode
I'd know everything I needed to know about setting
up secret Invasion that's all through incredible
writing and directing where it doesn't feel
frenetic it doesn't feel rushed it doesn't feel
um paced poorly in dialogue or style we
talked about cinematography but overall the
actual tension in the show comes from the concepts
like you you know the stakes you know the World
building because it's giving you Exposition
in almost every scene but the concepts are
so heady and the world is so uh aggressive that
it doesn't ever feel like it's about two people
talking in a room and it is like this show is
very much sitting and talking and it's that's
what good spy shows are to me and they nailed a
really unique tone that I did not know they could
um this is up there with like the Loki pilot for
me and Loki's my favorite show so like this is a
really special debut uh one division's up there as
well but like those are the ones that are the most
different like the Loki was so existential and
Wanda division was so mysterious this is is so
spy Cold War you mentioned missed impossible we
mentioned a bunch of things I I didn't know that
that Marvel would I mean there was there were so
many jokes in here I was like that is an adult
joke like they really went with not a Disney
plus audience here I'm really impressed yeah
but the jokes are still within the character
100 there's nothing jokey it's jokes that are
like you'd have in a cold war there's nothing
that feels that that Marvel humor complaint
that people have often lobbied against the MCU
you don't get any of that here at all I love
Fury post blip I love that IT addresses so many
things that I wish they'd addressed sooner yeah
they really do they give you this this really
clever way of setting up Nick Fury where it's
see what's cool about we're talking a lot
about plot and mood and atmosphere all these
things what they did an excellent job at doing
because the exposition makes sense that you're
dealing with a lot of government bureaucracy
a bunch of different people and factions and
alliances so you have to spout the exposition
because there's Mission driven so you have to
give the exposition so it's well Justified but at
the same time it's so character driven everything
everything is motivated by character choices and
then the the personal feelings that everyone has
like I love the position that Talos is in of
he does not want a war whatsoever and he's he's
sympathized and he cares even for the people that
he's against like the last thing he wanted to do
was kill that scroll who was on the opposite side
of his belief system and it you see that it puts
him at odds with the way how Sam Jackson decides
to handle it or Nick Fury decides to handle with
actually killing him he's really bothered
and disturbed by it the last thing he wants
is death for any of his people because despite
the difference in beliefs he doesn't want any
of them to die so I love the position that puts
Talos in but for Nick Fury especially what they
did a really great job at doing normally Nick
Fury no matter if he's gone Rogue or it is at
the top of the agency you feel like in some way
this guy's in control in some way this guy's got
a mastermind position and you could see that he is
a lot of people keep commenting on it he's not the
Nick Fury that he used to be and that's more than
just like I'm grizzled and and more Rough Around
the Edges that's it he he lacks in certain ways
because there's there's conflict within himself
there's a lack of confidence within himself
as well as he's you know dusting off the old
fill in the phrase John Dustin off the old the old
Earth body or something you know what I mean he's
getting back into the field you know the saddle
yeah yeah that's where I'm trying to go with that
yeah because with Nick Fury they they put him in
a position where I I find myself actually rooting
for him instead of going he's got this handled
and I thought that's how I might feel like he's
got this handle he's gonna say some like badass
[__] I love that he's actually an underdog and
they he's not a full Underdog but he's just enough
of an underdog and yeah the way how they deal with
the post-blip situation with his performance
I wonder whose choice that was because that's
something that they've acknowledged about post
split that they've talked about and like sir like
Falcon Winter Soldier tried doing it when you know
he's trying to get a loan up with it comedically
yeah but they don't really this is the first time
like wow the performance here is so human of like
this is the this is the Disturbed character that
I've been waiting to see after such a horrendous
event you know that that happened within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and I love that it's
a movie one actor I love that it's Nick Fury who
we've been with for so long who we care about so
much Sam Jackson who we're invested in I really
love that the exemplification of the trauma of
the blip is is through new fury because I wouldn't
have expected that like I I love that we've been
wanting something and a lot of times Marvel does
a good job being like this is the character that
embodies this whole thing you want yeah I'm
really surprised and impressed it's Nick Fury
I'm really enjoying this performance yeah and uh
Olivia Coleman Estonia I thought was an excellent
scene as well there's just a great writing and
character scenes throughout that's what bummed
me out so much about Maria Hill dying at the end
of this I really wanted her to get to play because
this yeah that's the feeling like Kobe smolders
I really wanted Kobe to get to play like it's
about her I really kept feeling like damn this
is so cool we finally get to see Kobe's Smothers
well she has such presence like her performances
are really great and and she has just so you can
tell she's thinking Maria Hill thought she's
fully embodied the character and it's just
such a bummer to have the prospect of not getting
to watch more of that because you know like a lot
of people obviously know her from How I Met Your
Mother but she can like really act I know from
Jack reach would never go back of course that's
right well and I mean she worked her ass off to
try and save that like she's she's good in that
bad movie but like she's great well John uh what
did you think about Amelia Clarke as Gina oh
yes Rodriguez I liked her so far I mean Emilia
Clark is an actor who I'm still waiting to really
click into so that's right man no I don't want any
women on these shows all right that little girl
with the ball is too much for me in fact I want
men dressed as women like Shakespeare intended
yes but yeah I mean like as the outset of the
mission and for her relation obviously the
conflict between her and Talos and finding
out about the death of her mother and everything
like you know there's lots for that character and
I like wondering if she's a double agent yeah
um and I mean her presence just performance
wise I think is good so far you know again I'm
still waiting to be like I want to have those
I want to be talking about Emilia Clarke
like I'm talking about Kobe smolders right
now and I'm sure you know hopefully over
the show we'll get there but right now I'm
fitting introduction at the very least well
I really liked her scenes with Ben Mendelson
specifically I bought the father-daughter
relationship I like the duplicitousness
itself
to these words it is certainly that because
yeah it is cool though with the Scrolls that
they it there is truly truly literally not just
physically but emotionally all around uh and I'm
excited to see Amelia Clarke's uh roll grow here
at Olivia Coleman I thought was a nice presence
that opening see you know what really surprised me
about it was I was expecting something that just
kind of reminded me of Winter Soldier in its tone
because it's Marvel and at first I thought like ah
am I liking this more like Mission Impossible but
as it played out I likened it more to Old School
um Thrillers like Manchurian Candidate or uh
what's that Robert Redford all the presidents
yeah all the president's been so good yeah that
one uh like those kind of or like slow horses yeah
those kind of spy movies and it was less it's
in fact I started getting like action heavy I
was like oh yeah yeah yeah I was more surprised
by that because yeah I imagine there'll be they
got two tones that they're dealing with here you
got like an Invasion of the Body Snatchers type
of flare and close encounters obviously but then
you got they lean way more heavily into the uh
negative isn't it no I don't know yeah a
duality of tones it's just extra enhancement
yeah that was that was a good show I was really
impressed with uh not only are they improving I
think on the comic I like secret invasion in the
comic but I don't think it's like uh I just don't
love event comics and and the book feels very
much like it needed to be an event this feels
like the corner of Marvel I've been waiting for
it's actually improving on the event feeling of
the comic because I think that the grounded level
Marvel is much more interesting than Cosmic for me
A lot of times yeah uh and what they're able to do
here is is really make the most uh a supernatural
thing an alien invasion the most grounded
show yeah I'm so impressed fascinating duality
all right well before we end this drone what you
think of the music I like the music quite a bit I
thought it was uh nice it wasn't two in your face
but it definitely bolstered those classic Vibes
you're talking about uh I'm gonna have to hear
more of it to really kind of log the the flavors
of the show but thus far I thought it was good
it enhanced everything without distracting me at
any point uh but what do you think about the Pod
security scroll played by uh James McNaughton my
favorite character listen up all right there's
a whole other conspiracy that's going to link
to this one specific character so keep a lookout
for pod security scroll moving forward because
he's gonna be the key to everything and uh you
call I called it so just when that happens I
want you all to acknowledge you know that I
called it all right well I'm just excited it
looks like Grace Boyle who's an acting double got
an actual role a White House age has promoted so
I like any time a little uh day player role
gets happening so congratulations Grace Boyle
don't worry guys alrighty guys I love the
show well what did you think about our
Premiere episode of secret invasion was there not
enough Marvel comedy for you there's not enough
CGI action for you great to see Don Cheadle
how does this tie into the Multiverse Marvel
doesn't have a plan what's going on here look at
your thoughts down below subscribe leave a like